gnarrk and now it's time for how to be a
pirate
coming from dead stars pump black above
bill some call me but only with a drunk
is my real name is Howard I'm doing here
to teach a hall to be a pilot today
we're gonna be looking at oh now there's
a big controversy about hooks you see a
lot of players claim that you have to
have your hand cut off in order to have
a hook but I disagree I would like to
start a new movement a movement I like
to call hooks aren't just for people
without hands are the abbreviated
version well you can also that I have to
admit the movement hasn't had many
members basically it's just me and Ariel
the mute they always find she can't say
no to anything it says more than your
words that are Troy
incidentally there's also some
controversy about what kind of hokey I
should get some use for others your
spoons I know this one fellow who used
to use a spatula we used to call him
crazy isn't that right mr. Harrison if
Jesus was alive he punched you in the
ball not the skinny fella neither
metaphor watch etho Fat Albert was a
molten Newton personally myself how do
you like to go for the most treacherous
of all steel Pollock apparently I got in
some trouble with some things I
shouldn't have done with a real for
example don't shake hands ladakh unless
you want the hook face to really catch
on also don't go turning pages when a
hook it'll ruin many a copy of Harry
Potter picking your nose probably isn't
a good idea unless you want to hook for
a Knowles and finally never circumcised
with all your laws many Jewish pirates
net week isn't right mr. Goldman Amita
he's going to surpass even as all your
books are in Braille
course it could be because he had
something in his eye and I tried
scratching out for him that reminds me
now I'll go up to someone who has
something in their eye and try to
scratch it out for them they don't make
hooks for eyes still there are some good
things that can be put for use with your
hook hand picking your teeth is very
handy fishing is a no brainer
cutting umbilical cords to again dull
circumcision and the courts bindus tree
these are handy little devices for 10
I would however recommend that you be
Adventists again found that out the hard
way I don't want to say specifically
well let's just say toothless Joel can
pronounce my name anymore
toothless Jo oh sure you were saying
something positive man some ugly
prostitutes gotta pay not too sweet for
them
speaking of which now if I use one of
these on a prostitute she will take away
somebody wants to specifically and again
books don't replace those very well
please the only thing that sleep with
you is a car turn yourself that's done
over week ow
woman so larger cup sizes a salad so
what and lighting is just like mocking
us say if you want to bring some people
in you've gotta have a good hook and
preferably not innocent blood-stained of
it
Hey Berman troupe and Stark revised as a
virgin year did you climb back into your
mother the ape
not much on I think are either vessels
to maybe for penguin was contagious but
in reality of a woman for I II know the
tales of blood the beer beer Joe what do
you say live should I tell you about
stories about the great they see that
blood beer Joe so menacing that the Sun
puts on blood beer Jolla blood beer Joe
is so focused that he wants beats are on
the eye of evil in a staring contest
please say that recently a life-sized
replica of love beer Jules penis was me
they say that bored the beer Joel once
walked up to the pearly gates kicked
them down walked up to God's house look
them in the eye and said your seat blood
the beer joel has a chainsaw for know
warheads for buttocks pour the beer Joel
ship is so mighty that he once
challenged the morning Padre sir on the
earth they say that the Pirates of the
Caribbean movie what originally going to
be about blood the beard show but I
can't protect X but nothing from his
awesomeness blood the beard Joe is so
intelligent that he watched the ending
of 2001 a Space Odyssey instead true of
this so everybody know he's a glass
topple at the beard job she may not be
God oh wait yes join me next time for
hope will be a pirate see you soon
this war is how to be a pirate the
greatest show that ever we are tired
have you all heard stories about the
board the beer Joel I betcha I'll just
send it to this such a nice right here
and it just might make it into the next
episode but send them quick because by
you awesome quick